ich weiß mittlerweile was beim ein video
das ist gut so was geht ich war wieder
ein solcher prozess erst mal gar auf
jeden fall ihr seht ihr schon wieder
eine panne ein herz und ich diese drei
dinge zusammen
das kann auf jeden fall nichts gutes
bedeuten ja ich habe mir gleich mal
wieder was ganz besonderes überlegt das
letzte video ich berate die duh ist
wieder durch die decke geschossen bis in
den himmel
was der am meist weit entfernte zwar
nicht auf dieser welt also im universum
meist ganz welt zu saturn ist auf jeden
fall frei letztlich habe ich heute von
guten kollegen schöne grüße an dieser
stelle man wollte ich mal sagen was sie
denken nämlich folgende aufgabe stellten
zwar alex du machst deine scheiße testen
doch wissen mal für mich ob man auch
jetzt hält euch
so nun ist auch klar ist ob man weiß auf
tiefkühlpizza raten können die arbeit
wir machen erstmal die pässe aus zülpich
da diese gute salami und margerite route
geht nur in der reifezeit mit man sagen
die versuchen wir jetzt mal zu beraten
ich hoffe dass dieser fünften wird immer
gehalten wie gesagt immer bei 50 auch
gleich jetzt das nächste video anbieter
aufgefallen letzten jahr habe ich nicht
wie du du schauen gebraten sondern wie
dem creme zum premium duschen 1 1 war
das andere pflanzen fliegender
teemischung also ja deswegen hat ganz
klar du schrauben muss auch noch
gebraten werden
vielleicht mach weiter so der herbst an
gestattet
hier sieht apple hat die höchste stufe
angedreht groß und das ganze hin und
heute brauchen wir natürlich wieder
etwas sonnenblumenöl damit das ganze ein
bisschen pfeffer bekommen ich bin sehr
gespannt meint ins laub doch als mac
dann auch ne also so weit es mit sagen
wir zeigen etwa die pizza in vier stücke
weil es faktisch nicht reif war für gut
2 30
soll ich vielleicht mit dem erstmals
durchschneiden vielleicht fange ich
einfach mit zwei stück haben oder noch
besser drehen und schon wieder vergessen
frauen stehen haben schon leute wenn ihr
bei euch holt und die halt im ofen
fertig macht und dann auch immer so
probleme hat die zuschneiden schneidet
ihr einfach vorher noch nie einfach das
geht nicht
wie hoch ist die distanz
[Musik]
ok ich kann mir vorstellen dass es
richtig schmeckt arbeits könnte jetzt
könnte auch gut schwimmen zu uns war
sich weiter gar nicht da kommt immer
dieser draht geschmack zu und wird auch
wieder an dieser stelle macht es zu
hause nicht nach vor allem nicht wenn
mami oder papi zu hause bin und so das
ist unendlich bitter abrät bar nicht
bezahlt man im backofen es sei denn
damit dass meine schauen wenn ich sage
erst richtig gut macht gerne aber
grundsätzlich ist ein experiment die
wolke ausprobieren durch die sucherei
wollen mit den vielen lieb war und jetzt
als die fischer von hitze halten
vielleicht wird aus größen der ganze
käse hinweg ist der kein käse mehr außer
hier also ein bisschen ich denke wir
haben also die stadt haben jetzt den
franciso andere leute funktion von
durchschlafen die konferenzen wenn ich
in einer pfanne mit öl leute das kann
ich jetzt mal kurz an sprechen ob er
vorher muss ich aber wieder die pizza
binden sagt mal ganz ehrlich da wo er
herkommt sagt man ja oder nein zwei
monate mitglied der eu
hierbei kann fall ganz klar ersichtlich
wird
[Musik]
omega leckerbissen zu probieren gleich
frauen ist weil er blut in der toilette
sonstigen lage dringend etwas meinte wie
lange sich das leisten was man in der
aufnahme
man sieht schon lecker aus oder guck mal
hier der boden wie von sternekoch
ich weiß mittlerweile gar nicht mehr wo
oben und wo unten war solch ein stück
noch herausnehmen der probleme sind
dieses mal meinte das ist schon durch so
kann man sagt internet guckt euch das
mal getan ich meine das ganze gibt oder
das ganze öl was ich rein gemacht habe
das hatte ich schon förmlich in die
pizza gesagt jetzt einfach nicht mehr
drin
[Musik]
oder man das nicht doch nicht
wahrscheinlich sein schmeckt mega gut
hin
das ist jetzt erst mal gut zwei jahren
vier stücke mehr personal für jede
person ein stück okay ich fand's gut
schmeckt dann natürlich auch gegessen
die salami sind einfach sie sind etwas
zusammen führten diese salami sind etwas
zusammen gebraten
wer möchte die salami schon lecker aus
man sagt ja immer das auge isst mit
und heute muss das auto mal ganz
besonders mit essen weil ich dann kann
es echt gut schmecken ich vor mir das
jetzt nicht
was meinst du nicht weißt du wer mir
probiert es fertig das fußbad und lecker
[Musik]
gut dasteht absoluten und sich dass es
schmeckt einfach nur noch selbst ja
nicht gerade so noch sichtbar
wir brauchen ein backofen gebraten
natürlich noch aufgesetzt
ich wollte erst mal sagen so viel besser
gefallen uns die nächsten partie völlig
offen was ich noch hier
wenn dieser wunderschönen fahne alles
zubereiten wir sehen uns dann am freitag
wieder oder am sonntag keine ahnung ich
wünsche euch etwas noch einmal hab ich
vergessen und von snap